uh matthew i struggle with networking
and connecting with other comics they
make me feel
like the old man looking in i produce
shows but
have never been asked to do a spot on
any show that's not my own i get down
because i think they don't get they
don't think i'm funny i know dan soder
said that jealousy is
part of it but how do you get through it
great question matthew i can tell you
from personal experience
i feel the exact same way which is why i
started hot breath
pro to begin with because it's the
comedy scene
that i wish existed when i started
comedy 10 years ago because i was never
on the cool shows
i was never at the cool table
nobody was giving me comedy tips so hop
up pro
is now the community that we can all you
know be accepted as long as we're
willing to
be nice and be funny so just know you're
not alone in that feeling as well as
earlier we talked about amanda
having that self-doubt around her
writing and comedy you're not alone in
this
and i think what's going to help you
just keep doing you
matthew keep producing your own shows
those are the shows i could get on
the ones that i produced those are the
shows i could get on
so it's this is a common thing with a
lot of comics
is why doesn't my scene like me how can
i get in here
but focus on what you can control
so what can you control you can control
when you write you can control what
other shows you produce
you know you can control your own
destiny your own career
you can't control what cool bar
does a show at you know 4 a.m
at the buffet but if you don't have an
ironic beard then you're not allowed to
perform on it you can't control
if you get on that or not but you can
control the shows you do you can control
you getting opportunities outside of
your city so if you're looking for
opportunities in
a comedy scene look outside of your own
city see if there's other
shows that you can tap into and things
like that
but have you tried also i would say
something that i didn't do that much of
um
is hang out at shows do you hang out at
shows that much because i
never really hung out at shows that much
i really just like went on stage and
then left
on to the next one uh so i honestly
didn't make
that much of an effort to network in
those early days
and i know been people that i know that
did
got further along whatever that means
you know now in hindsight of doing
comedy 10 years
further along is you know
it's subjective what further along means
what making it means
is subjective but i have found to be
most rewarding is what i've been able to
create
uh myself the podcast you know my shows
my own tours
things like that have really would have
been the most rewarding for me
so i would challenge you to start
focusing on
what you can control and start
controlling it more
and it's a process but the more you do
it the easier it'll get
and the more you'll be able to start
controlling and focusing on what
you do have versus what you don't have
is another good thing to think about
because that's we getting that negative
feedback loop of
oh i'm not getting booked on any shows
no one likes me i'm never going to make
it in this game
but what you focus on expands so focus
on what you do have you have these shows
you produce you have this awesome
community here at hop breath pro
you have shows you get to do with fellow
hot brethrens like
kevin that you guys took a photo with so
it is that's a good note as well from
lee is seek out
those who are like-minded you know you
can't be friends with everyone
yeah and that's what kevin yep kevin was
saying
he hates people that leaves after their
sets unless you have another booked gig
stick around and support the room yep
yep that's a good note as well
yeah and that's something that was
booked on multiple shows
i would just leave as well which doesn't
really play well
you know as someone who hosts the show
for several years you know you would
like the comics to hang out and support
it
so there are things i could have done
better and at the end of the day that's
something i could have controlled
i could have controlled if i stayed the
whole show or not um so just focus on
what you
do have what you can control matthew and
you'll start to find it
you'll start to see more things that you
do have and more opportunities
you know i don't want to get too deep
here but you know it's it's the the ras
the reticular
activating system it's kind of like if
you buy a toyota then you start seeing
toyotas everywhere
it's the same thing on what your
thoughts are and what you focus on if
you start focusing on what you do have
you're gonna start seeing more things
you have around you but if you start
focusing on what you
don't have then you're gonna start
seeing that more and more you're gonna
start seeing more evidence of that
hey hop brother and sister and if you
enjoyed this comedy tip
subscribe to this youtube channel and go
join
our facebook group to have your
questions answered live
on next week's q a